look who called in to talk about his
dolphins because the Dolphins make him
cry Darius Rucker congratulations on a
big win that screwed up your draft pick
so well done you know we're out here to
either win football games
hey man we're gonna win out and go to
Super Bowl oh is that where are you
right now where are you right now I want
to go of course I mean I thought you had
a knee issue oh yeah I'm getting that
done later that's all I wanna go please
like I can't play you know that are you
get wait are you getting a new knee yes
yes yes the old guys getting a new knee
yes that's crazy man doesn't that sound
like a country song
the old guys getting oh okay what is the
worst it's song title that you guys ever
came up with or thought about oh I don't
know the worst song title we came up
with the worst band name
Benny was worth it horses hooting the
Blowfish uh Dean Dean said we should be
a black and blue because I was black and
they all had your eyes weren't Hootie
and the Blowfish then you would have
been black and blue blue yes yes black
and blues might have been better
yeah okay
do you like the Dolphins game plan here
of winning as many games as possible and
the coaches are trying to win you know I
understand what the owners are doing and
fun officers trying to do but you know
you gotta put a team out there and
they're putting on a table and their
guys trying to work up all gays and I
love it why did you sing the dolphins
make you cry like what was there a
moment that they made you cry the first
time the Dolphins made you cry oh oh
yeah they made me cry when I was five
years old
so the first time and I mean I mean I
would physically could upset and that
whole line came to my house when I was
in college
a freshman in college if my mom calls me
on a Sunday when I was born I'm being
really really short and I'm talked to
her she looks at the TV which you
realized the Dolphins lose ichigo's boy
you cry up on me that's okay
yeah but yeah I used to really cry when
they long after the own like the one or
15 season though the tears stop we're
talking to Darius Rucker you know the
first time I heard the dolphins made you
cry I thought it was the actual dolphins
and like you got really sentimental when
you saw dolphins for some reason I
didn't know it was the Miami Dolphins I
know a lot of people did I heard that oh
yeah when are you getting your lead okay
yeah all right if I can help you with
that because those first three weeks
you're gonna hate life right here no you
will don't be afraid to take the
medicine they give you and that ice
machine you put on your knee is gonna
save your life it yes your kids will
want to be around you maybe a little bit
hi buddy that's Darius Rucker big
country star and lead singer hooting the
Bluefish for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]